the funny thing is is this video started
as me just trying to learn about an
Instagram trend that we're gonna find
out if people know what the Barbie see
trend is where people imitate Barbie
speed and it somehow turned into
something really quietly different oh
this makes me feel concerned and worried
dude it's okay you're ugly is that
Barbie
[Music]
so why did I decide to try to become
life-size Barbie the idea first came to
me when I was asking people on the
street questions about Barbie feet I've
not heard of the Barbie trend they're
going like this pretending you have a
high heel on like go on your tiptoes it
makes their butt stick out there they go
can it one get your leg we can't look
more toned if people feel that it's
unrealistic then they don't need to wear
heels
her hair her waist her proportions
pretty unattainable for who me when you
are born that is the body you're giving
all I want to look like Barbie is like
Barbies plastic like what we imagined to
be like a pretty girl tall and slim and
like her makeups done all the times
Barbie has unrealistic proportions maybe
she is pretty perfect we all want to be
like her I can't imagine a real person
looking like that people kept talking
about her unrealistic body proportions
and I just got to thinking like can I
have her perfect proportions you saying
you don't think that I can make myself
look more like Barbie oh you can look
just like Barbie if you want but is that
what you want is that what anybody
really needs to be happy that is the
question if life is about being happy do
you need to look more like Barbie to be
happy and the answer excuse me and the
answer is absolutely not yes I want to
look like Barbie I mean I didn't really
think that before today but her body
proportions I can figure this out I need
to figure out what Barbies real-life
proportions would be and compare them to
my own a lot of people make the mistake
of measuring Barbies height from her
head to her tippy-toes which is
incorrect you have to measure to the
heel you don't go to the doctor wearing
high heels and measure yourself to find
out Barbie's sizes in real life you need
to time to all her measurements by 6
like her height actually ends up being
my height which is perfect and it's like
okay here we go but then she has um some
freaky proportions for instance her
waist it's about like around a 20 inch
waist
20 21 inch waist which I can't make my
waist up in size ever so I have to
one-to-one from somewhere and then ever
make everything else bigger that's the
only way I can do it it is become like a
math problem
that I need to solve I got the numbers
now I just got to make them reality I'm
gonna Barbie her feet are minuscule ok
feet feet feet feet ok like a little
looks they're over three centimeters
when we do her the math on this multiple
by 6 then we'll times a 1.3 - Bart needs
to be about 7.8 times larger than actual
Barbie in order to make any sense that
way I can have a waist
in order for my thigh circumference to
make any sense or I need to make myself
taller I need to make my hair longer I
need to make my hips bigger but my boobs
can pretty much stay the same turns out
she is pretty like average even below
average sized breasts and so do I so
it's kind of nice I'm gonna bring in my
friend Johanna she is a doll expert
hopefully she'll be able to help me
figure out how I can become Barbie I
guess I have some experience with the
dolls I've purchased a lot of haunted
dolls off of ebay that's my main
experience with the right like a doll
expert with a speciality and the Haunted
type sure I'm trying to make my body
like Barbies because I feel like I was
challenged to do it by some people out
on the streets I just want to prove that
I can I would say my relationship to
Mary the Haunted doll is a lot different
from your relationship to Barbie because
I have never tried to look like a
haunted doll okay you have a lot of
numbers written yeah I do okay
there's a lot of Marisol all of this
makes me feel concerned and worried why
oh my god this is like a job for
engineer Barbie hmm I think I need to
gain make around 19 inches in height Wow
so my Haunted doll for her height she
has like a doll stand
I feel like stilts maybe you're similar
to like a doll stand yeah Sarah how are
you gonna hold a mic
I need to make my butt bigger I need to
I guess kind of pinch in my waist her
head is much bigger so like I basically
need my head to go from this to this
um it may be like a helmet or something
like that
okay her hair is long but that's easy
it's like a wig you just get really a
long ass wig the one other big issue I'm
having for pupillary distance I did the
math is double my people in existence
wait till like her eyes are farther
apart than you are okay I think I'm
gonna need to draw on some eyes though
yeah for sure for sure okay yeah I love
doing makeup I love doing special
effects makeup do you get a lot of
people coming to you asking to look like
Barbie never never
I probably done something in the fields
of the doll hey I need you to change my
eye to be like I think over here you
think you can do that yeah okay thank
God I could leave resin cover them we
can just start maybe I'm gonna become
the most attractive woman in the world
after this makeup is done oh my hours
gone most
[Music]
thank you look beautiful yeah I like
really good you look good
[Music]
yeah one of the eye
[Music]
right so we're going to glue these to
the top of your eye really really sick
[Music]
all right you are done check it out oh
my god I really do look very shiny in
plastic is that Barbie do you think
everybody will understand what I am when
they see me yes okay so I've got my
giant eyes and I've got my bigger tips
oh you can hear it my waist tied as
tight as possible so I'm getting more
Barbie shape so you can see what I've
done here is I taped up a helmet maybe
the eyes are too big
[Music]
did I do it do you think they did it I
mean I still need to grow taller but I
feel pretty good
[Music]
you know who I am
can you tell who I am could you tell who
I am yeah Tippi Hedren it looks like at
all if you have any guesses now
are you Barbie yes I am thank you do you
think from afar you would think that
Barbie became a real-life person if I
saw you
yeah well I might get fooled yeah I mean
I'm I'm easily full yeah it's kind of
unbelievable I'm in shock right now I
guess yeah I get it you're so tall you
know do you think Barbies extra but she
definitely does the most Barbies like
kind of known as having these
unattainable proportions but I'm here
out to prove that it is realistic and it
is attainable and it can be done you
look great
thank you look at my eyes they're closed
no you make them bigger
wow those are some serious eyeballs your
stance is also awesome super stable
seems like it'd be a lot of work to get
this old go yeah it was a lot of work
think you've got a lot of effort into
becoming Barbie thank you I measured
Barbie I found out that five times all
of her measurements by seven point eight
I could accurately be Barbie that meant
her head was begging her eyes were big
and yea-ah
but I figured out a way to do it I got
them exactly right so what what do you
mean so it looks like you're struggling
on the stilts yeah I wouldn't want those
it's no great what I spent days on this
it does make you look a little freakish
in that moment I thought of Barbie I
copied her proportions or height her
hair her eyes but I had forgotten to
copy her most important feature her
smile
Marty doesn't cry Barbie doesn't cry
Barbie always smiles I'm okay Barbie
doesn't cry Barbies not all she's
cracked up to it and I'm smiling through
the pain but I'm really upset right now
but Barbie only smile so I can only
smile right do you think it was worth it
I think anything that brings Barbie to
the forefront is probably a good idea
through a nice point that you know is
pretty ridiculous people need to
reevaluate why that icon was important
the first place
Barbie smiles no matter what honestly I
didn't even measure that it's the things
you don't measure that mean the most
Barbie feet is an Instagram trend
whereas Barbie is timeless you can't
become Barbie she's crazy proportions I
prove them wrong and I proved me
beautiful hey unsolved is on a new
channel and know your part subscribe
here
[Music]